leute bevor das video losgeht noch für
wichtige info und zwar am siebten und
achten august also in einer woche
unterhalten
doch ungefähr sind die video das in köln
falls sie da am start seit ich bin auch
am start
ich freue mich mega falls nicht kommt
auf jeden fall noch um also wenn keine
tickets hab dann holt euch noch welche
weniger köpfe und aus der umgebung kommt
aber wie schon gesagt und wir sehen uns
hey leute was genau ist willkommen bei
neuen video heute ist die flache stellen
strand ich weiß das hat eigentlich
wollte tipper oder sogar von aber wir
machen es trotzdem weil wir mega bock
drauf hatten
das ist der wusste der ließ die ganzen
land wie zuvor und ich spiele das
gegenlicht vom griechisch studios kennt
bestimmt keiner von euch aber müsste ja
und nein spass links in der beschreibung
aber später also nicht jetzt drauflegen
sondern wir fangen jetzt erst mal und
lassen dort nach oben da oder und stadt
meinte kommentare hohes lösegeld mit in
die comments anfang fällt baumgarten
der zweite ist reich an der gas zum
einstieg genutzt hat
welche witze sind eigentlich nicht
lustig und den verletzten sind auch
total diskriminieren aber bitte man nach
am häufigsten einmal wieder haben
man kommt nach hause seine ehefrau
johansson einzig flügelmann nein warum
ja dann habe ich wohl den kanarienvogel
guck mal kurz warum gibt es in amerika
keinen müller milchreis does not für
kleine das eigentlich nicht witzig aber
ich habe jetzt auch ein video zu gemacht
ich finde es nicht lustig aber das ist
halt schweiz noch mal aber das geht zu
weit
ich glaube jetzt wird sich glaub ich nur
einmal im monat kann sie es nicht anders
verdient haben
was ist ein futter spanien weit vom
fenster
schwarzer ist wie essen hat falls mich
jeder ich bin wieder rein zu schneiden
und zu woche
letzte worte unser pastor letzte worte
des sportlehrers alle sperre zu mir
wieso leben eskimos eigentlich sollte
sie können hat nicht ins gras beißen
was machen zu lassen vertreten
die musst du was bezeichnet man in
afrika als russen vorbei kleinen grauen
haaren
was macht eine frau auf eine eisscholle
ist doch klar
abtreiben
das war es erstmal in anderen feld
schickt das auch auf jeden fall ab für
den ehemaligen griechisch studios auf
dem kanal einfach link in der
beschreibung abschicken
ansonsten der kanal auch in der video
bestattung noch jeden fall auch wenn ihr
bock ablaufen und spielplätze fehler
sich manchmal verließ auf youtube video
verlinkt hatte und mich könnt ihr
natürlich auch abonnieren also nur wenn
ihr wollt halt ins alonso war auch alles
einbindet snap chat etc und ja